joining me today is the president of
Oklahoma Wesleyan University the author
of not a daycare the devastating
consequences of abandoning truth and a
staunch defender of intellectual freedom
on campus dr. everett Piper
welcome to the Reuben report well thank
you for having me I'm honored to join
you today I'm glad to have you because
you are writing about and talking about
and living many of the ideas that
obviously I focus on here before we get
to any of that though your other book
your first book I want to get the title
exactly right because it's just perfect
the title is why I'm a liberal and other
conservative ideas one of the things
that I've been saying lately is that
defending my liberal principles is
becoming a conservative position and I
think that probably sort of puts us in a
similar spot what what is liberalism
mean to you why do you consider yourself
a liberal well I would argue that what
you're doing right now is the historic
definition of classical liberalism let's
go back to the founding of the liberal
arts institution let's just say Oxford
1000 years ago why was a liberal arts
academy established it was to educate a
free man a free woman a free culture a
free church a free people it was an
education in Liberty an education in
freedom so the classical definition of a
liberal was somebody who argued for and
defended human liberty and it was in the
context of that education a liberal arts
education that Chesterton told us some
100 years ago that without fences you
don't have freedom and have without
honoring the big laws you don't have
liberty so it's this tension within the
liberal arts academy of pursuing truth
with a capital T that actually has the
paradox of releasing you for the
greatest measure of human liberty human
freedom in the course of human history
so a classical liberal liberal is
somebody who understands the
conservation you're conservationists
you're conserving those time-tested
truths that actually work to provide
human liberty so you ended on the word
worked there what what happened to
liberalism I mean if you
especially through an American context
today the people that call themselves
liberals and I'm not really talking
about the the classical liberals anymore
who have far more in common with say
libertarians than progressives
what happened to liberalism because I
believe as I think you do this is the
right set of ideas that the ideas that
I'm constantly talking about about the
individual and lazy Fair economics and
limited government or the light touch of
government I think these are really the
right ideas to move a free society
forward and yet what modern liberalism
is has almost nothing to do with that
let's go back to Richard Weber 1948 why
did he write his seminal work ideas have
consequences we hardly even need to
crack the cover to understand what he's
saying
ideas have consequences they matter good
ideas bear good culture good kids good
community good country good fruit good
ideas bear good fruit and bad ideas have
the opposite effect now why is 1948
critical in this analogy and my answer
to you it's because Weaver was writing
to his culture a handful of years after
what the Nazi Holocaust and he was
saying we should have seen this coming
we imbibed terrible ideas for decades
and we bore the consequences there ends
so we need to attend to the ideas that
have been tested by time defended by
reason proven by experience and I would
argue as a Christian given by revelation
it's those permanent ideas it's the
conservation of those ideas that are big
rather than dumbing down the
conversation to the million ideas that
are small again Chesterton get rid of
the big laws and you don't get liberty
you'd rather get thousands and thousands
of little laws that rush in to fill the
vacuum and if in if that isn't the
definition of our culture today I don't
know what is yes we are over regulated
and everyone thinks that there's just
another answer that lies in a law
somewhere and usually it doesn't so then
what do you consider yourself a
conservative now then or do these labels
even matter to you that much well I
would say a conservative is somebody who
conserves okay I believe in conserving
an owl and a tree and clean water and
clean air but I also believe in
conserving something perhaps even more
important that's ideas ideas that work
the Wesleyan quadrilateral and it's
actually actually all
- but let's go back to John and Charles
Wesley of the mid 1700s they had
something they called the quad the
quadrilateral and it was a worldview it
was the four things that you should sift
any idea through as you evaluate its
veracity tradition reason experience in
Scripture revelation if you will if you
want to get outside of the bounds of a
Christian language we'll call it
revelation natural law common sense
alright so tradition history
Grandma and Grandpa might have actually
known something the old ideas as CS
Lewis said are often better than the new
ideas if you want to read a new book
fine go ahead said Louis but you might
want to consider reading Oh a dozen or
so old ones first wise grandma whoever
weren't automatically backwards vases
well they weren't automatically stupid
in fact and I use that obviously as an
analogy the old ideas that have been
around for a while may be they're not
necessarily but they may be there
because they've proven themselves over
time yeah so history tradition
experience it's the dr. Phil question
how's that one working for you should
always respond to ourselves as we're
evaluating our own ideas our own
worldview as well as our adversary or
even those that agree with us and say
how is it working for us is there a
pragmatic value to this does it work
overtime for social health personal
health physical health whatever does it
work so tradition and experience reason
you've got a brain use it the
rationality facts versus feeling we're
in a culture right now that's dumbed
down everything to feelings rather than
facts facts be damned
yeah we're not pro science any longer we
ignore science for the sake of a
political popular agenda we're gonna do
if I'm gonna get to plenty of that and
then finally the fourth component of the
quod the quadrilateral is revelation
those things that are true and it
doesn't have to be tested into for
example the empiricist the materialist
would say if you can't taste it touch it
feel it see it just isn't so and I would
disagree with that and I can prove it
just by asking a simple question do you
believe that rape is wrong do you
believe the Holocaust was a bad thing
was Antebellum slavery something that
should have been
and the answer we all hold if we're
decent human beings as yes all of those
are objectively wrong well how do we
know you can't put it in a test tube we
know because it's a revelation Apostle
Paul one of the greatest philosophers in
human history I would argue suggested in
Romans that this is the truth of God
laid on every human heart others have
argued the Catholic Church and what not
that it's natural law common sense the
revelation that causes both of us to
agree both of us to agree that slavery
is a bad thing no it's not open for
debate
we don't have to test it in a - we know
slavery should be reviled all right
there's a lot there that's that's
bouncing around some of the ideas that I
talked about here so basically without
that that bedrock let's and we'll do
these backwards so we'll start with the
forth without that bedrock that
everything then would be left to some
sort of subjective nature right yeah
that's the the crux of that well so it
all take a guess as to power yeah if you
don't have a principle an enduring
permanent immuno principle it all
digresses to power and we see that it's
proven in human history
I'm fond of telling my students at
Oklahoma Wesleyan University in fact I
often give the commencement address in
May it's often very short I give them a
gift it's a guaranteed standing ovation
by the way to everybody before the
speech starts that this will be five
minutes max a five-minute comment oh yes
yes no not there - listen to me they
want to celebrate yeah but what I tell
them often and it's a repeat almost
every year today I'm not gonna celebrate
your opinion in fact today I don't care
what your opinion is and you shouldn't
care about my opinion I'm not gonna
patch on the back when you cry when you
walk across the stage and approach me
and you're funny cap and gown and me
standing there in mind I'm not gonna
hand you a diploma and say
congratulations you've got a degree in
opinions that's absurd
yeah I hope you paid $35,000 a year to
learn something that's right and just
and real and true true something closer
to the truth of your discipline than
what you knew when you came in as an 18
year old four years ago and the proof to
that you know some people may say well
that's just your opinion on education
good for you
well I'll say this opinions always
enslave but truth sets you free Pol Pot
an opinion Mao had an opinion ropes
Pierre Chavez and Hitler Mussolini all
the despots of history had opinions and
it didn't end well for millions of
people but Christ said you shall know
the truth and the truth shall set you
free there's power in the immutable
unchangeable truths that set us free and
there's always bondage in the opinion so
what do you make then of sort of what I
would say are the well intended
progressives and I'm not I think there
are some people without good intentions
maybe at the top of that but I think the
average young person that you're
probably encountering as a freshman that
has been sort of indoctrinated with
these ideas that follows through with
them like what what are the ways that
you've been able to sort of wake them up
to why this is wrong why why opinion
based learning is wrong why they're
actually are facts why why that matters
well I find the progressive mind and the
progressive agenda is so easy to knock
down by a rhetorical question in fact
again obviously in this interview for
thus far I've showed my cards I'm a
committed Christian yeah I believe the
words of Christ make a difference fact
George MacDonald once say and my once
said in my attempt to obey the words
recorded as his I have found grandeur
beyond the realm of any human invention
and therefore I cast my lap with those
of the Crucified that's good stuff so
what do I do
well well if I believe that this guy
named Jesus was actually who he claimed
to be
I'd have to kind of conclude that he's
probably the smartest guy that ever
walked the face of the earth he knew the
answer he knew how to win the debate but
often this guy that millions if not
billions of people have claimed to be
God incarnate that walked among us
didn't engage in an argument I mean you
read the story of Christ and he almost
never argued with his opponent mm-hmm he
could have won the debate
he knew how he could have crushed them I
would conclude but he never argued what
did he do he asked a simple question
which one of you wants to throw the
first stone why do you call me Lord
whose faces on this coin and then he
shuts up and he lets the world view of
his adversary implode as they drop their
stones and they walk away so what do you
do with the post-modern the progressive
question from a 20 year old well can you
tolerate my intolerance
do you hate hateful people are you sure
that nothing is sure do you know that
nothing can be known and are you
absolutely confident there are no
absolutes and then just shut up and
listen they don't have an answer they
sawed off the branch upon which they sit
and it comes tumbling down and it's at
that point I think you can rebuild the
argument with some common sense rather
than this nihilism and nonsense literal
nonsense because it makes no sense for
you or me to look and adversary in the
eye and say I can't tolerate your
intolerance it makes you the very thing
that you find intolerable yeah it's self
refuting I feel like you're sort of like
a college administrator from the future
this is sort of like the Terminator
you've come back to warn us about what's
gonna what's gonna happen in the future
here so let's back up a little bit just
tell me a little bit more about how you
got interested in these ideas were you
always sort of political did freedom and
liberty and and ideas always matter to
you was that saying you were taught oh
well you know you've asked a question
that could take way too long answer so
let me try to discipline myself to be
brief I was a blue-collar kid my mom and
dad didn't graduate from high school my
dad was a truck driver my mom was a
nurse's aide and a stay-at-home mom odd
jobs here and there we were lower
middle-class where it was paid to
paycheck to paycheck
when I graduated from high school I went
to work in an apple orchard with some
migrant workers and I also worked in a
local factory I did two jobs and working
third shift lunch what time is third
shift for I think that's three o'clock
in the morning or something like that I
sat down for lunch one night and this
gentleman who was working two jobs he
was a private business owner he had a
flower shop so he was working the
factory to help make payroll Wow
but he had a master's degree in
international politics or Affairs or
something like that an esoteric degree
and he looked at me over the picnic
table in the factor and he said why are
you here and I said to make money like
you he still wanted to go to college so
I washed off the grease
and I got in my expensive factory rat
car that I could afford as an 18 year
old kid yeah and I drove up the road
half-hour and enrolled at a Christian
liberal arts college that I was aware of
and the rest is history those doors
opened up for me to be able to do things
like beyond this show yeah and challenge
one another with some reasonable debate
and good thinking those doors öbut
opened up because of a classical liberal
education not a progressive one not a
leftist one but a classical liberal
education that liberated me to move into
various different venues of life that I
never would have been able to do
otherwise so as it stands now are you
kind of shocked at the state of what's
going on with young people at colleges I
mean the whole the whole purpose of your
book right it's that it's become daycare
sort of or some basic training session
for students for things that they should
have learned a long time before that
nothing you should know everything the
day you walk into college because of
course you're supposed to learn but that
they've missed a series of extremely
important ideas before they've even got
there is that was that when you first
realize that was happening hey when was
that and be were you shocked no I'm not
shocked because I've been seeing it
coming for decades and yeah you're
you're you're accused of being an
alarmist when you warn people of these
things yeah that'll never happen well
where are we right now so when did you
first see it sense that's something I've
been a college president for 16 years I
would say about the time maybe 20 years
ago when I was a vice president of
various different various different
segments within the Academy I could see
the shutting down the foreclosed mind
the unwillingness to entertain anything
that might challenge you and move you
out of your comfort zone which way was
it coming from was it coming from the
students or was it coming from faculty
or was it coming from administration was
it coming in every direction I think
it's I think it comes we've created our
own monster in fact when I originally
confronted this daycare thing it's
interesting if I may set the context for
the daycare stay please is that fair
segue let's do it I like I guess that
sets up their own segue okay so what's
the daycare thing about so at Oklahoma
Wessling universe
we still have required chapel every
Wednesday and Friday all the students
the faculty are in chapel this
particular day it was three years ago
Thanksgiving week Thanksgiving week so
just before the break one of my vice
presidents was the speaker in Chapel and
I know this particular guy very well
obviously and I know he always speaks
from a script he never had lips so it's
always a 15 20 minute homily at best and
he's done and it's from a script well
after he was done I wasn't in Chapel
that day I was working or something so
anyway he called me after he was done he
said hey dr. Piper I need to give you a
heads up I had one of our own students
today play the victimization card he
came up to me after I was done with my
chapel talk and he pointed his finger in
my chest he said you offended me you
singled me out and you singled my peers
out and I don't like it and I said to
Kyle the VP that was calling me to give
me this warning I said well what was
your talk about I was wondering as it
was a political was there sarcasm what
was going on he said you won't believe
this first Corinthians 13 now for those
that don't remember first Corinthians 13
is the quintessential love chapter of
the Bible love is patient love is kind
you've probably heard it read at a
thousand weddings okay so I said what he
said yeah I know I spoke on love today
I'm a monster
and we had one of our students that was
offended by it and I said send me a copy
of your speech again knowing that he
talks from a script or speaks from a
script and doesn't ad-lib I knew if I
read it I'd find if there was anything
offensive did he throw in a joke was
there some off-putting humor or sarcasm
I read it nothing first Corinthians 13
love is patient love is kind a 15 minute
homily on love and I've got one of my
kids offended by it so I wrote this
article I've been writing for the local
newspaper for the last 15 years or so
and usually when I write for the
bartlesville Examiner Enterprise if I
people read it people care on this week
I was a little different this one this
one I was a little frustrated so I
popped off my op-ed and I basically said
young man that feeling of discomfort you
had when you heard that sermon is called
your conscience and you might want to
attend to it and if you came here
expecting us to coddle you rather than
confront you if you think we're going to
comfort you rather than challenge your
character you're in the wrong place and
then I went on for another 700 words or
so and I concluded by saying my land
this is a university it's not a daycare
we expect you to grow up and that
article by the end of a week week and a
half three had three and a half million
hits yeah we're going to link to the
article down below because I think
people should read it yeah now here's
the point and I don't know if I'm off
task and I'll shut up and let's show
you're doing your own Segway but here's
the point when I wrote that three and a
half million people paid attention to it
by the way NBC Today cited it as one of
the top ten news stories of 2015 wow it
went nuts Canadian Broadcasting
Corporation Oxford England Drudge and
rare and Limbaugh and Beck and
conservatives and liberals and
progressives all covered it the college
president that called out his students
and said this is not a daycare grow up
yeah
why is this important what Graham what
grandpa or dad or mom has hasn't said
that to their kids I mean this was not
rocket science this was not high
scholarship I basically said what
everybody was thinking so why did three
and a half million care three and a half
million people care well here's we did a
statistical analysis analysis internally
out of the all the comments on those
three and a half million views well how
many were positive and how many were
negative 97% were positive and this was
on the Internet yes yeah yeah 97% were
positive and 3% were negative the poster
child for the positive the Atheist from
a very well-known University in Florida
Fulbright Scholar writes me a letter and
said Piper I read you're not a daycare
thing period I went to your website to
figure out who you are period as an
atheist I can easily dismiss your
religion and your politics and I do
period but on this issue thank you kudos
it needed to be said please carry on
that guy knew he that we had created a
monster it was our fault our industry's
fault the Academy the ivory tower has
created this mess and he understood it
and the monsters turning around to
mmm-hmm and he knows it you know who the
poster child of the negative was the
church Wow the church house oh you
offended the poor kid you hurt his
feelings so what was the offense taken
though specifically you tell me he said
also he never able write but he never
addressed like a specific no he he felt
uncomfortable he thought that sermon was
directed toward him well maybe it was
there was a time that where the church
was supposed to confront those things
that are selfish and narcissistic and
the self focus was supposed to be
corrected by selflessness and confession
I actually said in my article I'm not
gonna start issuing trigger warnings
before altar calls but sermon is
supposed to wake you up yeah good sermon
is supposed to perhaps instill some
guilt so he was offended because he felt
guilty for not showing enough love so
alright there's a lot there so let's
let's talk about first this atheist
professor in Florida for a moment what
do you make of someone that can take a
principled stand like that that in your
view of the way they look at the world
is missing sort of a critical piece I'd
say one of those four quadrants that you
discussed before what do you make of
someone like that I assume and I've had
a lot of discussions like this on a
micro-level you probably think he's I
don't want to lead you too much here but
you probably think he's a perfectly
decent person who may be living a very
moral good life but at a macro level you
see more of a societal problem is that
is that a Pharisee well I think ideas
have consequences again and I would in
no way suggests the people that disagree
with my religion are all immoral people
I mean it doesn't take five minutes of
research to prove to the contrary in
fact these folks that agreed with me in
my article that when I say this atheist
from the University of XYZ Florida
agreed with me and was the poster child
of that it's interesting many within the
secular community rather than the sacred
community if you want to draw that
distinction mm-hmm we're all about this
message in my speaking until they
figured out I was a Christian food and
then it kind of went cold
because Canadian Broadcasting I could
tell when they figured out that I
thought the solution was to return to
what Chesterton called big laws that
would give us the maximum amount of
human freedom rather your Christian
earlier or not rather you're agnostic
Anglican an atheist or Buddhist or
Baptists it doesn't make a difference
but these ideas that Chesterton defined
as the big laws the simple laws and
others likewise I would argue Adams and
Jefferson and Washington would agree
that these big laws were contextualized
to give everybody freedom not just those
folks that went to church on the weekend
and I would argue that history has
proven and proven that true even Martin
Luther King jr. proved it in his letter
from the Birmingham jail the context for
the fight for freedom and justice was
what the natural irrefutable
common-sense natural law of God that's
what MLK told us so we see these
examples time and time again in our
March for freedom you can't have freedom
without offense said Chesterton fact
Chesterton said if you want to build the
biggest playground in the world this was
one of his analogies let's just let's
assume that this community this near
neighborhood wants the biggest the best
playground in all of the United States
and you spend all of the money to create
the bells and the whistles and all the
toys and you want the kids in this
community to enjoy that playground
Chesterton said build a fence because if
you don't what will happen one of two
things either you'll start policing
these poor kids and haranguing them and
yelling at them and creating all these
little rules to control them so that
they are safe within the playground or
they'll run out into the highway and get
killed
so either way the kids will be
restricted or hurt if you don't build a
fence around the playground it's the
paradox of freedom and fences of Liberty
and law yeah I mean there's a lot of
current analogies there with you know
obviously there's a debate in the
country about having a physical wall at
the border right now and you can make an
interesting analogy to what's happening
in the digital space where we were all
we all had free access to all of these
platforms and then they start censoring
different people and because there are
no fences they put imaginary fences all
over the place depending on who you are
but you mentioned something really
interesting there which is that
he thought or that some of the people
thought that your ideas were good until
they figure out that there's a link back
to religion how much of that has been a
struggle for you in sort of the more
secular academic world generally maybe
not at your university but when you talk
to other academics who usually probably
shy away from religion or scripture that
sort of thing well it's always a
challenge but I let's have a debate are
you really a classical liberal are you
an open mind at my mind at academic do
you want to pursue truth or do you want
to construct it do you want to protect
your opinions is that more important to
you than understanding what the answer
is at the end of the day are we going to
trust a referee on the game and if we
don't trust the referee if we don't
define the boundaries if we don't have
some rules for the game it's chaos you
can't play basketball without boundaries
you can't play soccer without somebody
blowing the whistle it's the paradox
again of Liberty in law if you're a
musician you know this if you don't
learn the rules of rhyme and rhythm and
cadence you're not performing in
concerto it's chaos and if you're an
athlete if you don't discipline yourself
to the rigor of the sport
if you don't memorize the plays if you
don't attend to the rules if you don't
pay attention to the coach if you don't
go day in and day out even though you
may not be that good yet you will never
be able to be free to actually perform
in the game and that paradox is relevant
when we're having an academic or an
intellectual or a political or a
theological or whatever discussion and
debate what are the higher standards for
the discussions so that we can actually
be free to do this how much of this do
you think boils down to what seems to be
a degradation in personal responsibility
amongst young people in the last let's
say 20-some odd years that there's more
of an you know people are spending more
time say playing video games and I say
this as someone that like I tried to get
you to play PlayStation a half-hour ago
you know that I like video games but but
that people are spending all sorts of
time doing things that are that are
almost the obvious success of a society
that we have every
we really just have everything doesn't
mean that every individual has
everything they want but you have the
world at your fingertips all the time
with the phone in your pocket and that
because of this access to everything the
personal responsibility part the part
that says I got to go get that job and
at 3 in the morning having 3rd lunch and
all of these things that that has sort
of just disappeared well there are a
variety of you could claim that the
church is responsible for its own demise
the schools are responsible for
educating their own monster that's
consuming them right now
you could also lay blame at the feet of
parents that are helicopter parents and
they don't allow their kid to feel or
sense or experience any adversity in
life we're gonna coddle it we're gonna
comfort we're never gonna confront and
build character we're just going to make
life easy for our kids and I see that
over and over again when the parents
drop their kids off at my campus I can
tell you in five minutes where the kid's
gonna be a problem or not based on how
the parent is behaving is mom angry
because doesn't like the drapes in the
dorm do they attend to every single
desire that the kid has if the kid ever
has any conflict or with a roommate I
want I want it I want it changed now
rather than forcing their son or
daughter to deal with relational
conflict with conflict and become a more
mature human being as a result the
helicopter parenting is greatly
responsible for a lot of the softness of
the soul and softness of our culture if
it's called the agon agonise tease the
wreck wrestling match if there's no agon
if there's no agonise tease if there's
no wrestling match if there's no agony
that's where we get the word then you're
going to be soft as iron sharpens iron
let one man sharpens another there is
testing by fire is as we become adults
in life and if that testing hasn't taken
place you're not going to perform on the
field
you're not gonna perform in the band or
in the orchestra you're not gonna
perform in a variety of venues in life
because you expect everything to be
comfortable yeah or in the intellectual
battlefield I mean I mean that's the
point that well that's why I try I do
try to link this back to personal
responsibility whether ultimately it's
from helicopter parenting or a poor
education system or a series of things
because if you've if you've ceded that
personal responsibility then all of the
offerings that that say the left offer
is now a free this free that take from
some give to others they all it all
sounds really great because you've
already abdicated your responsibility as
a human so that seems to me to be the
core issue if we could just get these
young people to wake up so okay so a kid
walks in to your school
mom's complaining about the drapes the
kid doesn't like his roommate whatever
the other series of things are are you
actually personally involved at any
point in this or tell me it just a
little bit about how the structure of
the university works so that you can get
some of these ideas across Oklahoma
Wesleyan is a small institution or about
1,500 total all in that's healthy for us
you know that's a financially healthy
institution but it's got the magic of
community you're not lost as a number
and you actually engage with the PhD you
don't just get an education in the
classroom of 800 to 2,000 students so
where you're being taught by the
graduate assistant that doesn't care
we've got a ratio of 1 to 15 1 to 16 and
you're actually learning from the
scholar which I would argue is good
education as opposed to somehow inferior
education just because you're smaller
than the big guy down the street mm-hmm
I think we've lost the power of
education as we've started worshiping
this altar of size and the behemoth and
the football program and whatnot that
somehow is better education and actually
learning like this come on that's
ridiculous in fact if you go to Oxford
now all of the various different ancient
colleges are really not much bigger than
Oklahoma Wesleyan they've just been
around for a thousand years yeah it's
pretty incredible I've been there twice
in the last year I spoke there which was
probably the biggest honor I've ever had
professionally and then I went back with
Jordan Peters in a couple months ago
exactly and it's shocking when you see
that these small colleges the way they
say it's it's so brilliant actually that
they set it up with all of these small
colleges in this in this truly I mean it
feels magical it feels like a Harry
Potter book this magical little place
it's just incredible well and it's good
education because you're being taught by
somebody who has wrestled the egg on for
years and years and years and he may
disagree with you vehemently but that
Socratic method draws
the conversation to a close where if
you're going to disagree with the
scholar you better know why and you
better be able to defend it otherwise he
will challenge you tear you down and
send you back to do your homework so
that you can come again another day to
carry on the battle that's good
education it's not soft education it's
not coddling education it elevates the
value of confrontation it elevates the
goal of actually being a responsible
human being at the end of the day that
actually has character more than just
wanting a career in the United States we
think that somehow good education is one
that just gives you the ability to get a
career mm-hmm I don't disparage that you
should be able to get a good job but
really is that where we are in the
United States where information is more
important than ethics and money is more
important than morality and getting a
career is more important than character
there was a time not that long ago where
all of those things were important in a
liberal education because we wouldn't be
free as a culture without them so what
went wrong there when when did that go
wrong you could argue that it proceeded
Weavers work in 1948 I would argue it
goes back to do it ii do ii and the
model of education that prevailed at
that time where we stopped caring about
the the Socratic logic and the facts of
education we started caring more about
the feelings that come with education
and the common core debate they don't
really get people stir it up yeah yes
Common Core is a joke why in the world
would we want to dumb down education to
the common to the average don't we
believe that education should pursue
what's excellent and exceptional
Common Core puts everything at the at
the level a level table of average of
common that's why it's called that it
doesn't release my faculty and others to
do what they know how to do best I don't
need the government telling my faculty
how to build a syllabus I just don't
need that yeah if I have hired a math
professor that doesn't know two plus two
is four there's a solution I fire him
and I go get somebody who knows how to
come
to the right conclusion I don't need
someone else trying to intrude and
govern that discussion and Oklahoma
Wesleyan faculty has been ranked by CBS
News money watch as having the best
faculty in the nation for three
successive years by student review by
student review so why in the world would
the Fed think they need to tell me how
to structure education so what's the
structure we do it small we can engage
as a faculty and as an administrative
body to develop a curriculum that works
because I hire scholars and educators
that know what they're doing
and we have dialogue and relationships
with students as we get them to pursue
truth that's one of the cornerstones of
our mission statement you pursue truth
you don't construct it and at the end of
the day you practice wisdom you practice
what you preach you just don't have the
cognitive and the intellectual you
actually develop into a person of
character that engages culture with
integrity do you find that you get other
administrators other school presidents
and board members and probably donors
all sorts of things from other schools
that are reaching out to you go and how
do we fix this mess because I find now
that it's people ask this has come up on
the show many times it's like how do you
fix this thing and it seems like it
really can't come from the academics
because they've been sort of in it too
long and you mentioned to me briefly
before we started out there they're
often not brave and we should explore
that a little bit but that it really has
to come from the donors that only when
the money starts getting cut off will
the schools be willing to do the right
thing but I assume people look at you
and see what's going on and go that's
what we should be replicating well some
do but on any industry protects its own
and until there's a huge crisis people
are never forced to change and I'm not
sure we've reached that point of crises
in the educational industry in the
United States yet we will yeah do you
know what do you think that would look
like actually because I think a lot of
people are watching this going we're in
the midst of it the crisis is here it is
here intellectually it is here morally
it I mean you see it in the snowflake
rebellion this is education where
they're going to protest ben shapiro
library
and Berkeley's supposed to be the
birthplace of the Spree free speech
movement but you're basically protesting
a guy who says the same things that
Ronald Reagan said that were mainstream
conservatives they're protesting a
conservative Jew and calling him a Nazi
this is an upside down claim that makes
no sense and anybody with half a brain
can figure that out but yet Berkeley
silences ben shapiro and others because
of what they don't like his ideas that's
not the birthplace of free speech that's
ideological fascism that is not academic
freedom in fact where do we get the word
fascism it comes from the root word
fascist a fascist was a Roman bundle of
sticks that was bound together so
tightly that it could not be broken you
see it in a lot of the frieze work in
the sculptures in the United States the
Supreme Court and in our Capitol you see
a fascist which often has a hatchet head
in the top of it what is it what does it
represent the power of the bond the
common bond which isn't necessarily bad
but it's from that we get the word
fascism that you must be one of us you
must look like us you must think like us
you must walk like us you must talk like
us or you're verboten you will be
expelled we will crush you Berkeley and
Shapiro we will crush you with the
fascist its intellectual its ideological
fascism that is not academic freedom
it's the antithesis of a classical
liberal hmm so I'm curious
Peter Bogosian who you may know he's a
professor up at Portland State who I've
had on the show a few times and just did
these faux academic papers we have them
on again in a couple weeks he calls this
postmodern set of ideas a secular
religion because it has all the markings
of a religion but there's no redemption
narrative and certainly if you're a
white cisgender heterosexual Christian
male you better bow forever and never
challenge it because you you have
original sin basically I don't know that
you've thought about that specifically
but do you like that as someone that
comes from a religious perspective do
you do you like that framing of this
that it has the markings of religion in
a negative sense let's say no I would
argue every worldview has the marking of
a religion either positive or negative I
don't think there's
anyway you can get outside of the box of
a religious discussion you and I might
disagree on that at another time in
another place but I think everything is
going to boil down to these key
questions origin of man nature of man
redemption of man and responsibilities
of man and all of those are religious
questions where do we come from
what is our nature what if it what does
our Redemption how do you fix the
problem and then what is our
responsibility at the end of the day
that's another quad if you will
quadrilateral for things through which
every human being
sifts his worldview in terms of trying
to resolve how to function with one
another and within life post modernity
I'm gonna butcher this historically
anybody out there that's a good
historian is gonna just fingernails on a
chalkboard don't worry we've got YouTube
commenters and they'll gladly touch it
I'm sure you're doing it sure yeah I'm
gonna separate human history into three
simple categories pre-modern modern and
postmodern what's pre-modern
supernatural in pre-modern there was
this idea that truth could be
experienced this is real this table is
empirically verifiable I can touch it I
can see it I can feel it but there were
other things in pre modernity there were
also real and those were revealed truths
mosaic law for example there was a
revelation that gave truth to man so
pre-modern was supernatural modernity
comes along and it became what simply
natural pre-modern supernatural
modernity simply natural if you can't
taste it touch it see it feel it then it
just isn't so pre-modern modern so
what's post modernity if pre modernity
is supernatural and modernity is simply
natural what's post modernity Superman
the ubermensch we shall rise up we will
decide we will define we will declare
ourselves to be as God the original sin
is defined in Genesis we don't need
anybody telling us what to do now
whenever humanity comes to that point
what always happens it ain't good power
yeah power crushes dissent
pre-modern supernatural modernity simply
natural post modernity of the ubermensch
Superman and I would argue that's where
we are right now
so how dangerous or precarious let's say
of a position do you think we're
actually in in the United States right
now or just let's say the West in
general because this idea is growing
we're fighting it back there that it's
you know there's there's definitely some
pushback online but if you look at
academia if you look at the political
establishment if you look at the media
these ideas are gaining and gaining
strength if you look at the way the
media treats the ideas of Alexandria
Acacio Cortes they're making it seem
like these are all the hot right ideas
these are pretty radical socialist ideas
but they have an incredible amount of
momentum right now what kind of position
do you think we're actually in right now
at the beginning of 2019 well I'm an
optimist I I know the end of the story
and we win truth will prevail at the end
of the day what happens between now and
then that's a matter of discussion in
fact I had an old boss he was the
president of my alma mater I worked for
him as a vice president and he was
afraid of flying and one day I pulled
dr. Chapman aside and I said what is the
deal I said you're a Christian you're
deeply committed why are you so afraid
of flying you know what the end of the
story is he said I'm not afraid of the
end of the story I'm just afraid of what
happens between 13:1 I don't relish that
two minutes so what's gonna happen in
that two minute gap of history I don't
know I'm not a prophet but what I can
say is these ideas are dangerous and
they're nothing to just dismiss and if
you're a classical liberal that
disagrees with my religion and my
politics if you're a classical liberal
that wants liberty at the end of the day
you better pay attention to this debate
because you have things that I just
looked at this morning on the news
before I came here where Nancy Pelosi is
proposing that laws should be in play
that if parents are parenting improperly
as defined by her and her party that the
government should actually have the
right to take the child away so if I've
got a ten-year-old boy and the way he's
behaving sexually is something that I
think is unhealthy for you
should I have the right as a parent to
pursue counsel for him or should the
government be able to intrude and tell
me no you don't have the latitude to
parent that ten-year-old boy the way you
want to those discussions are in play
right now and again if you disagree with
my religion and my politics that should
bother you because religion and politics
will change the powerbase will change
right and what's popular today won't be
popular tomorrow and then you'll be on
the losing end
you better care about something more
permanent and enduring immune Abul true
the devastating consequences of
abandoning truth truth will set you free
not Nancy Pelosi well I think that we
got the promo for this episode right
there how enthused to you that these
discussions are happening also outside
of the academic world right now you
mentioned the Jordan Peterson you
reference him in your book that would
that this guy's on this world tour I
happen to be on it with them but that
these conversations even with some guys
that maybe you don't agree with on a
believer side of things say of sam
harris or the rest of this this crew
that people really care about these
discussions where i would say five years
ago people online weren't you know
people are watching cat videos and
people being you know kicked in the nuts
and a couple other things but they
weren't really having these discussions
and now they're they're on fire online
so that that's pretty hopeful I do think
it's hopeful and again if you trust
truth if you trust the referee if you
trust the whistle then play throw elbows
rebound knock people over do what you
need to do trusting that the game can be
played and I think that's the magic of
the conservative worldview the
conservation of those big ideas that
allow you to engage that's the beauty of
the traditional liberal arts Academy
trust truth to win the irony here I had
somebody when Milo hit his snafu a
couple years ago somebody called me up
and said are you gonna have Milo at your
campus because he had been dismissed
from Berkeley or wherever it was I said
no because I don't agree with Milo on so
much that I don't want to lead anybody
to conclude that somehow I'm elevating
his ideas to some level of acceptability
within our culture I said how are they
let me play here so if a Stu
if a student group on campus had invited
him would you have allowed that to
proceed if that's a little bit different
than someone asking you will you have
him if a student or a student group
wanted to discuss his ideas I let's go
at it those ideas can be discussed
robustly and you'll engage with our
faculty and the rest of the community
and vetting those ideas who's right
who's wrong there are some times when
here's an example let's get off mile for
a second for me to answer this question
I had another gentleman who's very
well-known and very popular across the
nation who wanted to speak at my
commencement but he's of a different
religion now had he accepted my
invitation which I issued to be part of
a day of co-belligerent francis
schaeffer where he and an evangelical a
Catholic conservative Jew would have
come to the table to have a discussion
in front of the students in terms of how
to be Co belligerent for a common good
of common sense and common morality pick
a topic the preservation of the sanctity
of human life that would have been a
great thing but putting somebody that
disagrees so much with the core tenets
of my institution at my pulpit at my
podium on the key event of the Year
commencement is something that I guard
because it sends a signal to everybody
so I didn't I didn't invite him to the
commencement I invited him to a day of
co belligerence does that make sense
yeah yeah you know I'll defend your
right as a private institution to write
do what you think is best but let's get
back to Milo would I put Milo at the
podium at the pulpit I think I have to
guard the message of what we stand for
mission aliy right but would I put him
in a different venue where there would
be debate and disagreement and a good
exchange that's a different question if
that answers you and I suspect the
answer is yes to that question yeah
possibly yeah I mean I'm gonna make a
decision there are some people I'm not
going to because they're so far outside
the pale I'm not gonna put a white
supremacist on my podium because I think
it's offensive - I mean we were birthed
out of the civil rights
movement we were actually birthed the
Wesleyan Church was an abolitionist
Church we could stand against slavery
so our history our mission is human
equality and it's it's we stood in the
face of the Civil War and said no we
will not do this and it's out of that we
birthed ourselves out of the Episcopal
Methodist Church and became the Wesleyan
Church because orange got Luther Lee
believed that it was wrong to call a
human being less than a human being the
definition the imago Dei of what it
meant to be human was something that
they would not forfeit may forfeit and
they held on tenaciously to that
definition thus the Wesleyan Church so
am I going to put somebody at my podium
that refutes all of that it's a judgment
call that I have yeah so right
interesting do you think that
universities you probably don't want to
say this as a administrator but that
perhaps the way we're learning relative
to people watching videos on YouTube and
conversing online and all these things
that the way young people are learning
is changing so rapidly that 10 years
from now or 20 years from now that the
university system is gonna be completely
different I think that's a far gonna
conclusion perhaps but not just
different but far less relevant that you
will have figured out ways to learn in
many other ways I mean I say this all
time now it's like if you just watch
this show not that it's a complete
version of what you should get in
college obviously but you can have you
know behavioral scientists and
evolutionary biologists and clergymen
and and a wide set of people from
different walks of life you can learn
from them and if you want you can get a
pretty damn good education that way
that's not the complete piece of why you
should be a college but do you sense
that that's really changing oh there's
no question I mean you've got micro
going back Tucker Carlson all have been
very aggressive in the last six months
on advising parents not to send their
kids to college because of the flaws of
the Academy this daycare nonsense
the lack of robust debate the debt that
you're incurring to get a terrible
education that's basically
indoctrination rather than intellectual
afternoon
and I don't necessarily disagree with I
think there are a handful of
institutions left that care mm-hmm but
literally I'm not sure it's much greater
than a handful so yes education would
change but here's the shame of it when
it changes and becomes more online and
technologically driven you're gonna lose
this mm-hmm and if you lose this you
lose half of what education is about if
these same ideas were expressed from a
distance in an email exchange or in a
text exchange or if you saw me speaking
online you might think that guy's a
jackass because we haven't had that
maybe you think that any kind we have it
not yet 'unity to actually develop a
relationship relationships are part of
the core and the soul of good education
that's what causes you to become part of
the human community part of being a
human being is the relationship and if
all we're gonna do is transfer
information through the internet rather
than engage in a relationship that
actually builds to a common
understanding of those revealed truths
that matter we've lost the core of what
it means to be an educated person in a
liberally educated human being yeah you
know it's funny I'm so intimately aware
of that because on in the last year
especially where I've been on the road
so much I see one set of ideas online
and a certain amount of hate and anger
and resentment and all of that and then
everywhere I go and I mean this without
exception I meet great people just like
this and you talk to somebody and it's
it's so much more powerful than the
conversation online so even though I'm
so enthused about people getting ideas
from these conversations and things like
that yeah the other part of that and and
maybe the colleges will shift and learn
to integrate some of that I hope I
suspect well those financial pressures
are huge right now I think Forbes put
out an article less than a month ago
that suggested that 50% of all colleges
and universities in the nation will
close in the next ten years because of
the financial pressures and as a college
president I understand why Forbes is
predicting that I would argue that the
handful that will succeed are those that
are clear and bold
distinct the marshmallow the mush the
vanilla will fail
now you may disagree with my Christian
paradigm you may disagree with the four
pillars of Oklahoma Wesleyan University
which are the primacy of Christ the
priority of Scripture the pursuit of
truth and the practice of wisdom that's
who we are we have a center for
capitalism free enterprise and
constitutional Liberty we are pro-life
we're the only University in the nation
that operates a mobile ultrasound clinic
free of charge to women in our hundred
two hundred mile radius we've saved over
two hundred lives as a result of doing
that now how many college presidents are
you gonna hear this story from all right
whew yeah and people listening right now
may say I don't want that fine go get
what you want it's a free market but
those that are listening right now
they'll like it they're not gonna find
any place else and they'll knock down my
door to buy it
nobody wants vanilla ice cream if you
sell a flavor that's bold and distinct
and clear and different the people that
want it will buy it
missional clarity is critical for any
industry any business and especially for
the Academy right now because if we're
all just vanilla mush then why would you
pay twice what you need to to get an
education from me when you could go down
the road to the junior college and get
the exact same thing it makes no sense
you've got to be distinct otherwise you
fail can you talk a little bit about how
the sort of the new studies say gender
studies and women's studies and things
like that have kind of infiltrated the
the more traditional disciplines that
that seems to be a big one lately
okay now you're you're pushing me here
so I'm gonna answer clear I'll let you
do your own segues for a while so I'm
gonna answer clearly it's a compromise
of the dignity of the one pure and
simple who's losing right now in the
academic discussion women why do I say
that
okay title nine is a 1972 law that was
established to give women equal access
to the field to the shower to the
scholarship to the bathroom to the sport
great law good right okay we've complied
with this started good
we've complied with that since day one
now under Obama I receive a letter like
every single college prison in nation
received demanding through a
bureaucratic Fiat not through
legislation
mmm-hmm that's a different discussion
that we immediately start providing
transgender accommodations on our campus
I responded and I said no no why did I
do that because I'm not sympathetic to
those that are wrestling with that just
for you or that particular issue of life
now I'm not that's not why I said no I
responded because I said this and I
actually put it in writing
how can I possibly comply with title 9
which you do II and OCR telling me I
have to do if I now deny the biological
fact of the female and start pretending
that women aren't an objective reality
but rather a social construct who's
going to lose if I do this mr. do-e and
mr. OCR women are gonna lose they're
gonna lose their scholarship lose their
sport lose their competitive advantage
because they're gonna be supplanted by
men who take it away from them and by
the way we see this now in sports all
the time every every whispers there's
another wrestler trans woman wrestler
that's beating a biological woman and
people are cheering this as if this is
the way it's supposed to be and how is
that fair and how is that pro woman the
irony again is as a conservative I'm the
classical feminist now because I'm
acknowledging the feminine and I'm
saying that women are real they're not a
social construct they're a biological
fact and they should have the
protections that title 9 afforded to
them back in 1972 and I refuse to
compromise that so I sent a letter back
to the DOA in the LCR and I said no told
them why and I received a letter back
saying you're exempt Wow at which point
I got criticized robustly as you can
imagine from anybody that disagreed with
my particular defense of the dignity of
the woman but you got the exemption I
did for now well now both now title nine
has changed because of the Trump
administration so well they didn't
change title nine they're just enforcing
it
pure way rather than trying to
manipulate it through bureaucratic Fiat
yeah the same thing was true on a
portable Care Act Oklahoma Wesleyan
stood with the Little Sisters of the
Poor on the steps of the Supreme Court
in defending the right of a bunch of
nuns to not have to buy contraception
they're celibate why do they need any
think why should they have to buy any
contraception and how is it possibly
pro-woman for the federal government or
anybody to tell these women what kind of
products they have to purchase in their
health care package when they don't want
them they won't use them they don't need
them and by the way they're Catholic
they're pro-life so the Fed intrudes
into all of that says you've got to do
this you've got to buy this product by
the way Oklahoma Wesley by definition
hires only pro-life faculty and staff so
the women at oku are pro-life - they're
not Catholic but they're pro-life who
can possibly claim to be Pro woman and
ignore the wisdom and the intelligence
and the right to choose but these women
should have in their health care we were
the ones that defended that we were the
only university in the nation to
challenge the bureaucratic Fiat that
suggested on sexual harassment that you
have to convene a kangaroo court on your
campus that you've now are required by
law to circumvent the local legal
channels and persecute the accused on
your campus by not allowing him to be
adjudicated by people that actually know
what they're doing local law
professionals and at the courts and it
also compromised the rights of the woman
the rights of the accuser because you
drought you were then required to drag
her before a committee of her peers and
go through the whole thing again it's
just completely bananas I mean we're
eliminating due process or that's what
exactly what it was Oakland Weston was
the only University in the nation a
Christian conservative institution stood
up and said no we will not do that fire
actually represented us and I was thrown
out and we prevailed all right I got one
more for you there is a sixteen
seventeen year old
watching this right now thinking about
what college they're gonna go to I think
you've done a pretty solid sales job
already but give them the final sales
job of why they should attend Oklahoma
Wesleyan will decide what you want okay
so first of all what product do you want
do you want a career do you want
technical training do you want an
apprenticeship then you might not want
to go to Oklahoma Wesley and if those
are the only things that you're
interested in if you also want to
wrestle with the big ideas if you also
want to do it robustly within the 1000
year tradition of a classical liberal
arts education which is not progressive
and leftist but grounded in those
time-tested truths you might want to
consider coming here and again I've got
to throw this in I can't ignore this we
are Christian if you want those four
things that I described the primacy of
Christ because we believe he is who he
claimed to be the prior of scripture we
believe that the Bible is more than just
an interesting dusty book okay we
believe that it contains the revelation
of those truths that actually give us
the ability to do this the pursuit of
truth truth is an objective reality
rather than just a postmodern construct
I'm not going to give you a diploma in
opinions I'm gonna give you a diploma
that demonstrates you learn something
and then finally the practice of wisdom
the practice of what you preach we're
integrationists head and heart fact and
faith belief in behavior personal life
in public life are integrated
we're not segregationists we don't
separate things that should be United
I'm the president of a university I'm
not the president of a diversity and
there's a reason for that the unity of
Veritas the unity of virtue the unity of
the verities the university is
historically something that celebrated
us coming together in unity bound
together by truth with a capital T it
didn't degrade in balkanize culture and
humanity into division we should be
teaching virtue and Veritas not
victimization and when you teach
victimization you get advice and you get
vengeance and you get violence that's
what you see in the protests in the
streets right now the solution to
anybody that's listening to me is get an
education in the virtue
in Veritas in truth it's more than a
career it's about something that
actually builds your character this is
the first interview I've ever done where
I wish I had to get into the
intellectual dark web card that I could
just hand you right now because it's
this has been a pleasure just sitting
with someone with the complete set of
ideas that that knows what they think
and is a master at it I've thoroughly
enjoyed this I hope you have as well and
for more on dr. Piper you can follow him
on Twitter yeah he's on Twitter for
better or worse it's dr. Everett Piper
[Music]